two of the most significant changes that
have occurred since I first started
using forms capture technology starting
with Gollum back in the year 2000 really
have had to do with technological
advancements and shifts in perception so
in terms of technology when I was
playing Gollum it was just motion
capture at first and though facial
capture and then I'd have to go back
into a volume and I'd have to act out
the scenes as Gollum and for a second
time to get golems and close-ups that
all changed really with use of the
facial performance capture which came in
when I started playing King Kong that
was the first time I used facial
performance capture which meant that my
facial muscles were driving the actual
character the next big change was the
ability to on the Planet of the Apes
movies take performance capture out onto
live action sets we were able to
untethered have head mounted cameras and
be able to play one-to-one with
live-action actors and not have to go
back and repeat I've always maintained
that acting using performance capture is
no different to any other form of acting
so I don't think you modulate or change
or adapt to your performance or you're
building an emotional center of the
character a psychology and physicality
you're embodying that role regardless of
whether you're playing a human being or
or golem or whatever character I mean it
really is the end of typecasting it does
mean that you can play absolutely
anything and I think it's a wonderful
gift and I think I think in a hundred
years time it'll be how people act if
you're working purely in the CG
environment it can be a little bit
unsettling but I would say to an actor
who is starting off don't be afraid
within seconds you will find you'll be
grounded in your character if you've
done the research it's absolutely no
different to being on stage or being in
front of the camera I'm incredibly
excited for for people that and envy
people who haven't tried it yet because
I really do think it is one of the
greatest 21st century tools an actor can
have in creating new performances